the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
if we go too fast any recovery will be
hindered
tonight on politics now we are improving
but not enough that was the coven
message from governor sisilak this week
plus his plea for labor day weekend from
marriages to pardons to voting i'll
explain all the ballot initiatives
that'll be on the november ballot this
year
plus i think it's a wonderful thing that
we get more eligible people to vote
dnc chairman tom perez tells us about
their voter outreach efforts in nevada
and why he thinks mail-in voting is all
about giving people options
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
clark county are raised to one
restriction for local restaurants but
most of our coven 19 precautions
are staying in place thanks for joining
us i'm orcomana
governor steve sissellac also pleading
with nevadans to be
safe this holiday weekend please help us
get through
this next weekend we had a major setback
after memorial day weekend
we had another one after the fourth of
july and this is our third big one of
the summer
as for those restrictions nothing will
change for bars but restaurants that
have bar
style countertops like sushi restaurants
or breakfast places
can reopen those countertops as far as
other restrictions
the governor says he's taking it one
step at a time
if we go too fast and recovery will be
hindered
and things like conventions won't just
be canceled this year
they'll be cancelled next year too and
the year after that
and we will lose convention business we
can't afford to do that
the number of cases has been declining
but the number of deaths has been steady
those deaths are people that contracted
coven 19 up to five weeks ago
and the state's percentage of tests that
are positive has not started to drop
yet hundreds of nevadans get a reprieve
for a month and a half as governor
sisalak extended a statewide moratorium
on residential evictions the extension
was for 45 days from this past monday
the whole point is to keep people in
their homes and to prevent an eviction
crisis in nevada
but the state and its counties have a
lot of work to do
i'm basically almost two months behind
armando gamez is one of the hundreds of
thousands of nevadans struggling to pay
for housing amid the coven 19 pandemic
his work hours have been slashed and
what he is making doesn't cut it
not enough to pay rent despite his
apartment complex doing what they can
gamez is still worried he'll get evicted
they point me to some programs and
that will cover a little bit of
of my problem they have been helpful but
it's not enough
i do understand the frustration that's
why governor steve sisolak is extending
nevada's eviction moratorium by 45 days
the extra time will allow counties to
continue paying out short-term rental
assistance to landlords and an
additional 10 million dollars will be
added to the program
i know our local governments are working
hard to get these funds out the door
to landlords to keep qualified tenants
in their homes
the 45-day extension will also give
courts more time to set up a new
mediation system between landlords and
tenants which should be up and running
before the end of september and the
state will continue to work through the
huge backlog
of unemployment claims we do not want
nevadans getting evicted while awaiting
a determination of their case
this break it helps us but still is not
enough
you need a job gamez says it's too
little too late and now he's planning to
move to arizona in search of work that
will pay his bills in full
there's no options here in terms of
processing unemployment claims governor
sysolak says
a new identity verification system
should help deter get benefits to people
faster
and he adds that five thousand claims
are expected to be approved this week
turning now to the november election
will have five proposed amendments to
the nevada constitution
that qualified for the november ballot
remember voters have to approve
all of these twice so let's take you
through some of them and explain what
they are
question one removes the board of
regents for the university system
from the state constitution that would
give the legislature
more control over the state's colleges
and universities
right now making a change means they
have to go through the five-year process
of amending the constitution the yes on
question no
question two people rather actually held
a launch for their initiative this
week question 2 would enshrine the right
to same-sex marriage
in the state's constitution same-sex
marriage is legal nationwide
but the existing language in nevada's
constitution recognizes marriages only
between a man and woman
this amendment also says that religious
organizations and the clergy
do have the right to refuse to perform a
marriage
question three would change the state
board of pardons that board is made up
of the governor attorney general and
supreme court justices
they would be required to meet four
times a year the amendment would also
remove the governor's ability to veto
a decision all on his own question four
would enshrine the existing voters bill
of rights
into the constitution right now that
exists in state law
there is no question five so we skip to
question six
this is the second go round for the 50
by 30
that would amend the state's
constitution to require utilities
to generate or acquire at least 50
percent renewable energy
by 2030 voters passed the measure in
2018
so this is its second approval governor
sisalek
signed this into state law but
enshrining in the constitution makes it
harder to change
down the road the pandemic makes
in-person voter contacts harder for
campaigns to do
so how are they compensating for it john
langler asked democratic national
committee chairman tom perez
about their nevada campaign efforts what
can the dnc do what can the the
organization do
to get to voters when based on the
pandemic
you're not really supposed to have a lot
of interaction period we've had our
virtual clipboards out
for some time and we've been able to
connect with voters the voter
registration advantage
continues not only in clark county but
across the state
you look at the progress we're making in
washoe county also
and the the beauty of nevada nevada is
really a model for the nation
we this pandemic has certainly changed
the nature of uh
how you interact with voters but over
the course of the last
six seven years the the state party
uh whether and then starting with
senator reid
and continuing on the state party has
built a remarkable infrastructure
uh and we're proud to work together uh
we are in every year
everywhere uh party in nevada and so
we're not meeting people uh for the
first time we're no longer the
you show up every fourth october talking
about voting to people
the investments that have been made in
organizing over a period of years are
serving us well
uh in recent years and i think we'll
continue to service well
as we head into this election cycle
nevada has mail-in voting this year
which is not normal
uh it's new for us here i know it's in
other states
from firsthand experience it's up in
washington state but
um the republican the trump campaign
thinks this is a situation that's right
for fraud
what do you say well i say that's
hogwash
uh the vote by mail it's safe it's
secure donald trump's been doing it for
years his wife does it
virtually his entire cabinet votes by
mail
you came to las vegas after a
distinguished career
in washington state they've been doing
it for some time out there guess what
happens with vote by mail whether it's
washington state
california arizona oregon
colorado now nevada guess what happens
it increases turnout
i think it's a wonderful thing that we
get more eligible people to vote
and what you have this year and again
nevada votes early.com is the one-stop
shop to learn more about it
you have options nevada is a in terms of
the people in
the top elected positions a democratic
state
governor senate congress etc
but from a national standpoint from a
presidential race standpoint
is nevada still a battleground
how concerned are you that the state is
vulnerable to
the president's campaign we're proud of
the progress we've made in recent years
to
not only elect democrats but to have the
first for instance majority
female state legislatures
as we do in nevada nevada should feel
very proud about that
and we were proud to be part of that
team at the same time nevada
will continue to be a battleground we
take nothing for granted
and we we are always mindful
that we have to earn people's votes
we put more of that interview with tom
perez on eightnewsnow.com
just look for the political news tab
allegations of
abuse of power and conflicts of interest
up next on politics now the i-team digs
into formal charges
from the judicial ethics commission
against a sitting las vegas judge
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
a las vegas judge is formally accused of
improper conduct and using her power
on the bench inappropriately this is a
story the i-team has been following and
vanessa murphy has the latest
judge melanie tobiason is accused of
abusing her power
letting family issues influence her
conduct and judgment
and failing to disqualify herself when
there may have been a conflict of
interest on the bench
she faces eight counts from the nevada
commission on judicial discipline in
this formal statement of charges
while charges from the commission won't
land her in jail they could get the
judge kicked off the bench
in 2018 judge tobiason shared her story
with the eye team
i would lose my job over this i would
lose my freedom over this i would lose
my life
over this she said she was trying to
save her teenaged
daughter from sex trafficking in 2015
her daughter started working at a now
closed store in chinatown according to
the commission judge tobiason believed
shane valentine a violent felon
was running a prostitution ring out of
the place and she told the i-team
she staked it out i spent hours i mean i
would go i would watch
i would get license plate numbers i
would get makes and models of cars i
would follow people i would get
information about where they would go
where they lived where they
you know i never used inappropriate
means to get information i did it all
myself
in 2016 sydney land and nehemiah kaufman
were murdered according to the
commission judge tobiason stated she
believed
valentine committed the murders and she
connected with sidney land's mother with
burner phones her code name master of
puppets
the commission states tobiason also
connected with a woman she believed was
involved in the murder once metro
believed the judge was interfering with
the investigation metro started tracking
her phones
and according to the department police
learned she had over a thousand
communications over five months with an
organized crime figure
who she had previously dismissed charges
against
in her courtroom police say she also
later communicated with him while he was
a fugitive
during her interview with the i-team
judge tobiason
admitted at times she turned to pimps
and
prostitutes for information instead of
police
the problem is i don't think we're in
danger from the pimps anymore
i'm more afraid of the vice detectives
and those who are trying to cover this
up
that's what i'm afraid of now the
commission is expected to hold
a hearing attorney dominic gentile told
me tuesday night he
is representing judge tobiason and he
did not provide
a statement vanessa murphy 8 news now
and after that initial interview with
judge tobiason in 2018
metro police responded with a statement
one of the judge's concerns was the vice
unit protecting pimps
which was investigated by the fbi
sheriff joe lombardo has insisted the
vice unit
has been cleaned up you can find that at
eight newsnow dot com
pushing for oversight up next the
congressional report
showing billions of dollars in fraud
waste
and illegal filings in the paycheck
protection program loans
plus i'm morgan right in washington
coming up the clock is ticking for
lawmakers to avoid a government shutdown
how they plan to tackle that
nine only on eight news now you're
watching
politics now
[Music]
a new report is out detailing how kovid
19 is disproportionately affecting
communities of color in nevada
the hispanic community remains the
hardest hit joe muller gives us a look
at the report
a 32 page report from the gwen center a
nonpartisan policy
center shows how the pandemic is taking
a toll on communities of color
latinos account for a the majority of
cobit 19 cases
the hospitalization rate for african
americans in clark county
is higher and then the kobit 19
mortality rate is higher for african
americans and asians
nancy brune is the executive director
healthcare access
lack of insurance and underlying health
issues are top contributing factors
of the folks who don't have insurance
here in nevada
latinos account for 60 percent of that
population
so overall about 20 percent of latinos
don't have
health insurance he says people of color
tend to work in industries directly
impacted by the virus
building services cleaning grocery store
workers
cecilia alvarado from me family of volta
is helping with histam tosmano's
campaign to bring awareness to the
hispanic community
she says fear is a big problem we come
from mixed status
families some of those families um if
they have someone undocumented they have
the fear coming forward to get tested
the report lists solutions such as more
education rental assistance and
more testing they don't always have the
option to call in sick they don't always
have the option to say i'm gonna
show up to work late today um so they
have to choose between
continue to provide to their families or
possibly going uh to get tested
joe muller eight news now to see the
entire report click on this story on our
website 8newsnow.com
it's september which means it's that
time of year where we start
counting down to a potential government
shutdown on october 1st
the federal government runs out of money
at the end of the month when congress
returns
next week it will have just a few weeks
to agree on a new funding plan
washington d.c correspondent morgan
wright reports on efforts to find
common ground in washington the clock is
ticking to avoid a government shutdown
we're going to have just a few weeks
before the october 1 deadline
and it's unfortunately unlikely that
we'll get all of our appropriation bills
done
maryland senator ben cardin says he
expects congress to pass a continuing
resolution
to keep the government up and running
but he doesn't consider that a success
continuing resolutions of failure not as
great as a failure of
letting government shut down but it's
not where we need to be carden says
besides avoiding a shutdown
a continuing resolution doesn't address
the new realities
government agencies face in the pandemic
you're freezing
the current year's budget into the next
year you're not establishing the
priorities that are needed negotiations
over government funding come as the
coronavirus continues to spread
some lawmakers say funding the
government and the next coveted relief
package
should go hand in hand new york
congressman tom reed
both of them have to be done in my
humble opinion and so we might as well
take care of
both packages at the same time reed says
at a minimum lawmakers should pass a
continuing resolution
to avoid additional harm to the american
people the country's going through
enough
it doesn't need the drama of washington
d.c
to add to it lawmakers return to the
nation's capital after the labor day
holiday
reporting in washington i'm morgan
wright
the last u.s federal government shutdown
started on december
22nd 2018 and lasted 35 days
it was the longest u.s government
shutdown in history
a small business group is suing the
trump administration for the names of
all businesses that got paycheck
protection program loans
and the exact amounts the american small
business league says so far
americans have little information or
transparency
about how the money was spent lloyd
chapman is the organization's president
publicly rated companies on the new york
stock exchange
and billionaires getting this money
congress is starting to look into who
received those loans as well
john langler talked with our washington
dc bureau correspondent
alexandra limon about it alex let's talk
about some of these problems what are
they talking about on capitol hill to
try and
deal with this yeah there's actually a
brand new congressional investigation
looking into ppp loans that was released
just this week
and what those lawmakers found was about
1 billion dollars
in potentially fraudulent ppp loans the
reason is that these democratic house
members say
that businesses some businesses obtained
more than one ppp
loan and that is actually a violation of
the program's rules
and they say those loans those duplicate
loans totaled about a billion
dollars so that is one big problem right
there but this congressional
investigation actually uncovered
a long list of other potential problems
with the ppp loans for example
they say there were hundreds of
applications for ppp loans that didn't
have any names
or addresses on the applications and
they were still
approved so lawmakers say in some of
these cases we don't even really know
who that money went to now treasury
secretary steven mnuchin was grilled
about this
issue in a hearing this week on capitol
hill and what he said was that any ppp
loan that is worth more than
two million dollars will be audited and
any
loan that was smaller than that can
possibly be audited and democrats were
pretty unhappy with that answer
because they're concerned that that
means that a majority of these ppp loans
will never get looked at
considering the speed behind getting the
ppp
off the ground the amount of money
involved are lawmakers
surprised that there's been this level
of fraud there's been this level of sort
of
lost money essentially with such an
enormous program
well i don't know if they're truly
surprised because you're right these
loans and this program was approved
so quickly but these lawmakers certainly
do act like they're surprised they say
that this shouldn't be happening
and they certainly seem outraged but it
is a good question you know whether
anyone can really be surprised
because you know those loans were
approved so quickly and in fact now
congress is trying to approve a third
round of possible ppp loans
that was alexandra limon reporting from
washington d.c